order statement the Prime Minister I
want to begin by echoing what you've
just said my gratitude to all members of
the house for assembling on a Saturday
for the first time in 37 years and
indeed to all members of house common
staff who have worked to make this
sitting passports meant people giving up
their Saturdays breaking into their
weekends at a time when families want to
be together and of course it means
missing at least the end of England's
World Cup quarter-final and I apologize
to the house for for that and I wish I
could watch him myself I know the
Honourable member for Cardiff West has
postponed his 60th birthday party if not
his 60th birthday to be here so Mr
Speaker of the House has gone to a great
deal of trouble to assemble here on a
Saturday for the first time in a
generation and I do hope that in
assembling for the purposes of a
meaningful vote that we will indeed be
allowed to have a meaningful brave
and with with permission mr. speaker I
shall make a statement on the new
agreement with our European friends and
the house will need no reminding that
this is the second deal and the fourth
vote three and a half years after the
nation voted for brexit and during those
years friendships have been strained
families divided and the attention of
this house consumed by a single issue
that has at times felt incapable of
resolution but I hope mr. speaker that
this is the moment when we can finally
achieve that resolution and reconcile
the instincts that compete within us
many times in the last 30 years I've
heard our European friends remark that
this country is half-hearted in its EU
membership and it is true that we in the
UK have often been a backmarker
opting out of the single currency not
taking part in Schengen very often
trying to block some collective ambition
and in the last three and a half years
it has been striking that members on all
sides of this house have debated brexit
in almost entirely practical terms in an
argument that has focused on the balance
of economic risk and advantage and I
don't think I can recall a time when
I've heard a single member stand up and
call for Britain to play her full part
in the political construction of a
federal Europe and I don't think I've
heard a single member call for ever
closer Union or ever deeper integration
or a federal destiny more PE your Bell
perhaps I've missed it but I don't think
I've heard much in you mr. speaker
there is a whole side there's a whole
side of that there is a whole side of
that debate that you hear regularly in
other European capitals that is simply
absent from our national conversation
and I don't think that has changed much
in the last thirty years but if we have
been skeptical and if we have been
anxious about the remoteness of the
bureaucracy if we have been dubious
about the rhetoric of Union and
integration if we have been half-hearted
Europeans then it follows logically that
with part of our hearts with half our
hearts we feel something else
a sense of love and respect for European
culture and civilization of which we are
a a desire to cooperate with our friends
and partners in everything creatively
artistically intellectually a sense of
our shared destiny and a deep
understanding of the eternal need
especially after the horrors of the last
century for Britain to stand as one of
the grand halls of peace and democracy
in our continent and it is our continent
and it's precisely because we are
capable of feeling both things at once
sceptical about the modes of EU
integration as we are but passionate and
enthusiastic about Europe that the whole
experience over the last three and a
half years has been so difficult for
this country and so divisive and that is
why it is now so urgent for us to move
on and to build a new relationship with
our friends in the EU on the basis of a
new deal a deal that can heal the rift
in British politics unite
unite the warring instincts in us all
and now is the time for this great House
of Commons to come together and bring
the country together today as I believe
people at home are hoping and expecting
with a new way forward and a new and
better deal both for Britain and for our
friends in the EU and that is the
advantage of the agreement that we have
struck with our friends in the last two
days because this deal allows the UK
whole an entire to leave the EU on
October the 31st in accordance with the
referendum while simultaneously looking
forward to a new partnership based on
the closest ties of friendship and
cooperation and I pay tribute to our
European friends for escaping the prison
of existing positions and showing the
vision to be flexible by reopening that
withdrawal and thereby addressing the
deeply felt concerns of many in this
house and one of my most important jobs
is to express those concerns to our
European friends and I shall continue to
listen to all honourable members
throughout the debate today to meet with
anyone on any side and to welcome the
scrutiny the house will bring to bear if
as I hope we proceed to consider the
withdrawal bill next week today this
house has a historic opportunity to show
the same breadth of vision as our
European neighbors the same ability
resolve to reach beyond past
disagreements by getting brexit done
and moving this country forward zazz we
all yearn to do this agreement provides
for a real brexit taking back control of
our borders laws money farming fisheries
and trade amounting to the greatest
single restoration of national
sovereignty in parliamentary history it
removes the backstop which would have
held us against our will in the customs
union and much of the single market for
the first time in almost five decades
the UK will be able to strike free trade
deals with our friends across the world
to benefit the whole country including
Northern Ireland article 4 of the
protocol states Northern Ireland is part
of the customs territory of the United
Kingdom it adds nothing in this protocol
shall prevent Northern Ireland from
realizing the preferential market access
in any free trade deals on the same
terms as goods produced in other parts
of the United Kingdom our negotiations
have focused on the uniquely sensitive
nature of the border between Northern
Ireland and the Republic and we have
respected those sensitivities above all
we and our European friends have
preserved the letter and the spirit of
the Belfast Good Friday Agreement and
upheld the long-standing areas of
cooperation between the UK and Ireland
including the common travel area and as
I told the house on the 3rd of October
in order to prevent a regulatory border
on the island of Ireland we proposed a
regulatory zone covering all goods
including agri-food eliminating any need
for associated checks at the border for
mr. speaker in this agreement we have
gone further by also finding a solution
to the vexed question of customs which
many in this house have raised our
agreement ensures and I quit unfettered
access market access for goods moving
from Northern Ireland to the rest of the
United Kingdom's internal market it
ensures that there should be no tariffs
on goods
circulating within the UK customs
territory that is between Great Britain
and Northern Ireland unless they are at
risk of entering the EU it ensures an
open border an open border on the island
of Ireland a common objective of
everyone in this house and it ensures
and it ensures for those living and
working alongside the border there will
be no visible or practical changes to
their lives they can carry on as before
I believe that this is a good
arrangement reconciling the special
circumstances in Northern Ireland with
the minimum possible bureaucratic
consequences add a few points of arrival
in your life and it is precisely to
ensure that those arrangements are
acceptable to the people of Northern
Ireland that we have made consent a
fundamental element of this New Deal
so no arrangements can be imposed on
Northern Ireland if they do not work for
Northern Ireland the people of Northern
Ireland will have the right under this
agreement to express or withhold their
consent to these provisions by means of
a majority vote in their assembly four
years after the end of the transition
and if the assembly chooses to withhold
consent these provisions shall cease to
apply after two years during which the
Joint Committee of the UK and EU would
propose a new way forward in concert
with Northern Ireland's institutions and
as soon as this house allows the process
of extracting ourselves from the EU to
be completed the exciting Enterprise of
building a new relationship with our
friends can begin
[Music]
I do not wish this project to be the
project of any one government or any one
party but rather the endeavor of the
United Kingdom as a whole
[Applause]
only this Parliament can make this new
relationship the work of the nation and
so Parliament should be at the heart of
decision making as we develop our
approach and I acknowledge that that in
the past we have not always acted
perhaps in that spirit so as as we take
forward as we take forward our
friendship with our closest neighbors
and construct that new relationship I
will ensure that a broad and open
process draws upon the wealth of
expertise in every part of this house
including select committees and their
chairs every party in every member who
wishes to contribute will be invited to
do so and we shall start by debating the
mandate for our negotiators in the next
phase mr. speaker the ambition for our
future friendship is contained in the
revised political declaration which also
provides for this house to be free to
decide our own laws and regulations I
have complete faith in this house to
choose regulations that that are in our
best tradition of the highest standard
highest standards of Environmental
Protection's and workers right no one no
one anywhere in this chamber believes in
lowering standards
a lot of gesticulation the statement by
the Prime Minister must be heard and it
will be the Prime Minister Mr Speaker I
am grateful no one believes in lowering
standards and said we believe in
improving them and seizing the
opportunities of our new freedoms for
example free from the Common
Agricultural Policy we will have a far
simpler system where we will reward
farmers for improving our environment
and a more welfare many of whose
provisions are impossible under the
current arrangements instead of just
paying them for their acreage and free
from the Common Fisheries Policy we can
ensure sustainable yields based on the
latest science not outdated methods of
setting quotas and these restored powers
will be available not simply to this
government but to every future British
government of any party to use as they
see fit
that is what restoring sovereignty means
that is what is meant in practice by
taking back control of our destiny and
our first decision on which I believe
there will be unanimity is that in any
future trade negotiations with any
country our National Health Service will
not be on the table
[Applause]
there's a speaker I am convinced mr.
speaker I am convinced that an
overwhelming majority in this house
regardless of our personal views which
is to see brexit delivered in accordance
with a referendum a majority and in this
crucial mission there can no longer be
any argument for further delay and as
someone who passionately believed that
we had to go back to our European
friends to seek a better agreement I
must tell the house that with this new
deal the scope for future negotiation
for fruitful negotiation has run its
course they said they said he said they
said we couldn't change a comma of the
withdrawal agreement they said we
couldn't abolish the backstop mr.
speaker we've done both
but it is now my judgment that we have
reached the best possible solution so
those who agree like me the brexit must
be delivered and who like me prefer to
avoid a no deal outcome must abandon the
delusion that this house can delay again
and I must tell the house in all candor
that there is very little appetite among
our friends in the EU for this breck
business to be protracted by one extra
day they have had three and a half years
of this debate it has distracted them
from their own projects and their own
ambitions and if there is one feeling if
there is one feeling that unites the
British public with a growing number of
officials in the EU it is a burning
desire to get brexit done and I must
tell the house again in all candor that
whatever letters they may seek to
enforce the government seek to force the
government to write it cannot change my
judgment the further delay is pointless
expensive and deeply corrosive of public
trust and people simply will not
understand how politicians can say with
one breath that they want delay to avoid
No Deal and then with the next breath
that they still want delay when a great
deal is there
the time
now is the time mr. speaker to get this
thing done and I say to all members let
us come together to end let us come
together as Democrats to end this
debilitating feud let us come together
as Democrats to get behind this deal the
one proposition that fulfills the
verdict of the majority but which also
allows us to bring together the two
halves of our hearts to bring together
the two halves of our nation let's feet
now both for the 52 and for the 48 let's
go this country let's go for a deal that
can heal this country and can allow us
all to express our legitimate desires
for the deepest possible friendship and
partnership with our neighbors a deal
that allows us to create a shared
destiny with them and a deal that also a
deal that also allows us to express our
confidence in our own democratic
institutions to make our own laws to
determine our own future to believe in
ourselves once again as an open generous
global outward-looking free-trading
United Kingdom that is the prospect that
is the prospect of this deal offers our
country it is a great prospect and a
great deal and I commend it to the house
the leader of the Opposition Jeremy
Corbyn
Thank You mr. speaker I join you in
thanking all the staff that have come
into the house this morning to help us
cleaning staff catering staff security
staff officials and our own staff
they've given up a weekend in order to
help our deliberations I also want to
thank the Prime Minister for an advanced
copy of his statement he has
renegotiated their withdrawal agreement
and made it even worse
he's renegotiated the political
declaration and made that even worse
we're having a debate today on a text to
which there is no economic impact
assessment and no accompanying legal
advice this government has sought to
avoid scrutiny throughout the process
and yesterday evening made empty
promises on workers rights and the
environment the same government that
spent the last few weeks negotiating in
secret to remove from the withdrawal
agreement legally binding commitments on
workers rights and the environment this
government cannot be trusted and these
benches will not be duped neither will
the government neither mr. speaker will
the government's own workers the head of
the civil service Union prospect
yesterday met the right honourable
member for sorry Heath and at the
conclusion of that meeting he said and I
quote I asked for reassurances that the
government would not diverge on workers
rights after brexit he could not give me
those assurances and as for the
much-hyped world-leading environment
bill the legally binding targets will
not be enforceable until 2037 for this
government the climate emergency can
always wait mr. speaker this deal risks
people's jobs rights at work our
environment and our national health
service we must be honest about what
this deal means for our manufacturing
industry and people's jobs not only
does it reduce access to the market of
our biggest trading partner it leaves us
without a customs union which will
damage industries all across this
country in every one of our
constituencies from Nissan in Sunderland
Heintz in Wigan Airbus in Broughton and
Jaguar Land Rover in Birmingham
thousands of British jobs depend on a
strong manufacturing sector and a strong
manufacturing sector needs markets
through fluid supply chains all across
the European Union a vote for this deal
would be a vote to cut manufacturing
jobs all across this country this deal
mr. speaker would inevitably and
absolutely inevitably lead to a trump
trade deal forcing the UK forcing the UK
to diverge from the highest standards
and expose our families once again to
chlorine wash chicken and hormone-free
to be
[Music]
this deal would I did say that the
statement by the Prime Minister must be
heard the response of the leader of the
Opposition the best traditions of
parliamentary democracy must also be
heard and it will Jeremy Corbyn ills to
enshrine the principle that we keep pace
with the European Union on environmental
standards and protections putting at
risk our current rules from air
pollution standards to chemical safety
we all know the public concern about
these issues all at the same time that
we're facing a climate emergency and as
for workers rights
we simply cannot give the government a
blank check mr. speaker you don't have
to take my word for all of this listen
for example to the tea you see general
secretary Frances R Grady who says this
she does she does represent an
organization she does represent an
organization that has six million
members affiliated to it this deal mr.
speaker would be a disaster for working
people it would hammer the economy cost
jobs and sell workers rights down the
river listen to make UK representing
British manufactures who say and I quote
this is make UK's comments on this deal
members opposite might care to listen to
them commitments to the closest possible
trading relationships in goods have gone
under this deal differences in
regulation between the UK and the EU
will add cost and bureaucracy our
companies will face a lack of clarity
inhibiting investment and planning
listen also to the Green Alliance who
said the deal amounted to a very sad
brexit read from a climate per sec
perspective the message mr. speaker is
clear this deal is not good for jobs
damaging for our industry and a threat
to our environment and our natural world
it's not a good deal for our country and
future generations will feel the impact
it should be voted down today by this
virus mr. speaker
I also totally understand the
frustration and the fatigue across the
country and in this house but we simply
cannot vote for a deal that is even
worse than the one the house rejected
three times the government's own
economic analysis shows this deal would
make the poorest regions even poorer and
cost each person in this country over
two thousand pounds per year if we vote
for a deal that makes our constituents
poorer we are not likely to be forgiven
for doing that mr. speaker the
government is claiming that if we
support their deal it will get brexit
done
and that backing them today is the only
way to stop a No Deal I simply say
nonsense supporting the government this
afternoon would merely fire the starting
pistol in a race a race to the bottom in
regulations and standards and if anyone
had any doubts about this we only have
to listen to what their own honorable
members have been saying like the one
yesterday who rather let the cat out of
the bag saying members should back this
deal as it means we can leave with no
deal by 2020 the cat has truly got out
of the bag so can the Prime Minister
confirm whether this is the case and
that if a free trade agreement has not
been done it would mean Britain falling
on to World Trade Organization terms by
December next year with only Northern
Ireland having preferential access to
the EU market
no wonder the foreign secretary said
that this represents and I quote a
cracking deal for Northern Ireland they
would retain frictionless access to the
single market it does beg the question
mr. speaker why can't the rest of the UK
get a cracking jail by maintaining
access to the single market the t-shirt
said and I quote it allows the All
Ireland economy to continue to develop
and one which protects the European
single market some members of this house
to welcome an All Ireland economy but I
didn't think that included the
government and the conservative and
unionist party the Prime Minister
declared in the summer under no
circumstances will I allow the EU or
anyone else to create any kind of
division down the Irish Sea you cannot
trust a word that he says
[Applause]
mr. speaker voting for a deal today
won't end brexit it won't deliver
certainty and the people should have the
final say labour is not prepared to sell
out the communities that we represent
[Applause]
we are not prepared we are not prepared
to sell out their future and we will not
back this sell out deal this is about
our communities now and about our future
generations
[Music]